morning firefighters some good news here  are making progress on the kaldor fire  as of this morning it's burned roughly  216 thousand acres but it's 48 percent  contained so that containment has gone  up families in south lake tahoe they are  waking up in their homes again this  morning following those mandatory  evacuations cal door fire was heading  toward the tourist area crews were able  to get it under control  people there as you can imagine were  glad to be able to return to a home  still standing we didn't know what we  were going to be coming home to but we  just could not be more happy to be home  the parking lot of heavenly ski resorts  still being used as a base camp for  firefighters at least for now  schools in the area they're going to  stay closed until all of the evacuation  orders up there have been lifted